he's a famous scientist right well he's
a famous computer guy i don't know
computer scientist he's not a scientist
he's he's a computer guy he's a monopoly
he's a famous he's a famous medical
doctor i don't think you would think so
a virologist not in my uh he works in
medical in some way uh no he talks about
it a lot i think he works in medical in
the sense of genetically engineering
mosquitoes to give you herpes or
something
that's slander he doesn't really do that
he does it to give you aids i'm just
kidding um no no it's it's it's uh uh to
what he's literally doing is genetically
engineering
him and his foundation i believe
genetically engineered mosquitoes that
are like sterile so they can reproduce
so that to eradicate malaria that was
one of the projects he's actually talked
i don't know how far the research is
he's actually talked about modifying
mosquitoes to get them to deliver
vaccines as well that's that's
terrifying what which is scary i know
where i think i think he said that but
he actually bought a bunch of uh stock
and the mosquito spray companies so he
knows everyone's gonna load up on that
stuff what's the uh the difference
between shareholder you know you know
i'm i'm i'm just want to point out that
i'm well past the point of hearing
something that sounds insane and
immediately saying it's insane because
we made alex jones on yeah and he told
us we were eating cloned beef and i was
like no we're not and then i googled it
and it's just true and then luke luke
rudkowski was like bill gates funded
microchips to uh for for a microchip
birth control for a win and i was like
luke come on and then i googled it and
it's just like
reuters reports it so we have
science.org
news guard certified 100 out of 100
researchers turn mosquitoes into flying
vaccinators as i was saying
so anyway they do say it's unlikely to
to take off but your point was that it
was being it's being it's being floated
and funded yeah so so anyway creepy
stakeholder capitalism is that we
replace shareholder decision making with
stakeholder decision making so these are
technocrats experts the experts will
tell us what the right environmental
social and corporate governance policy
esg policy will be to run a company
successfully in a sustainable and
inclusive way that's the language they
use a stakeholder a stakeholder for
instance stakeholder is somebody who
holds who represents people who they
claim hold a stake in what comes out so
if a oil company for instance creates
pollution
either directly or indirectly by selling
its product there are climate experts
who are going to be representative
stakeholders that are going to dictate
what that oil company can do and can't
do
so the victims of corporate waste are
the stakeholders in this situation no
experts are
experts who are appointed by other
experts in a closed network become the
stakeholders why don't we do this why do
why don't we do this let's make the uh
they've got a good track record for
danny economic forum oh yeah we'll be
held at my my uh new ranch for damastan
and uh i'll i'll be the klaus schwab you
can be the christian for freelance yes i
can be the canadian the canadian number
two okay thanks i didn't want to i need
your cat so i can yeah i don't want to
derail so so it's taking it away from
the shareholders which are the people
that have stock in the companies being
like i want the company to do this you
said this to a new unappointed
electorate of experts yes controlling
the economy from the top behind the
scenes okay correct and i can explain
how that works but we're still talking
about who class rob is and what his
ideas are so i could tell you because i
brought him up to talk about his book
and so it turns out he's got a number of
books uh fourth industrial revolution is
a book he wrote in 2016 maybe 15 i'd
have to double check the date but
thereabouts and he talks about how we're
transitioning into an entirely new world
we're going through because of high-tech
digital stuff we're going into an
entirely new world of synthetic biology
there's all these new high-tech things
everything is so complex he says there's
so much velocity to the changes moore's
law he invokes a lot of science he
sounded things he says we're in a
quantum state which that's always really
great and i don't think he's talking
just about quantum computers he's like
it's quantum business or something like
and so you know it's like deepak chopra
at that point who is also works with the
world economic forum really yes and so
anyway
the point i wanted to raise was
that
in his book that he wrote
in 2020 in
june or july of 2020 called
covid19 let me say very clearly because
it's a conspiracy theory
klaus schwab who directs this gigantic
future facing world economic forum that
has sought since 1971 to remake the
world economy and all of its tools and
has brought together the biggest world
leaders in governance corporations and
institutions to help do so in a yearly
meeting plus having thousands of
employees or at least hundreds of
employees worldwide
he wrote a book called
let me not stutter covid 19. the great
reset that's the title why did that book
come out in june or july of 2020
seems quick doesn't it
perhaps like four months into the
pandemic which was a very narrow window
of opportunity to remake our global
economy
you read the book i did read that book i
live tweeted about half of it because i
read that part in the back
how much of it directly talks
specifically about covet 19. almost all
of it wow virtually all of it and how it
can be used as a representative problem
that the the scale of problems that we
face i'll be honest i don't think he
wrote it he probably hired someone you
know i mean he's he probably brought in
a ghostwriter and he probably spent a
few days telling him write this right
this write this yeah i don't think it
out you know i don't i don't know any of
the circumstances around that that's
possible um everything he writes and
says sounds to me virtually the same he
writes a lot of this kind of visionary
pablum and then all of a sudden he has
this one weird paragraph in each of his
books because i've read
three of them and it's like that's why
we need global cooperation in a world
government to usher us through these
dangerous changes that we're having that
are coming so fast and um in this
long-winded uh explanation of who klaus
schwab is and where we go and i was
building up to this great reset book i
have to remember what was the point of
what he said in the grave oh yeah we
were talking about about this this this
supply chain kind of universe so he's
dead wrong in this book he's explaining
at that point that what's going to
happen is people are going to be so
scared of pandemics that as we come out
of 2021 or so what we're going to face
is a massive demand crisis people won't
be willing to engage in goods and
services anymore and so now we're going
to have this problem where employers
aren't going to be able to employ people
at all because there's no demand for the
products because nobody wants to go back
into a virus-ridden society and they're
all scared and they're all hiding in
their basements like joe biden did
before the election
and
as it turns out we have the exact
opposite problem we're trying to pay
kids 20 something bucks to flip burgers
at mcdonald's and they won't do it this
is the ubi thing right so ubi is
actually kind of in his whole like
programs so you're gonna have a more
inclusive economy you give more people
money they're more included into the
economy they can participate in the
economy they have resources to
participate he actually talks about the
inclusive economy in this regard and so
it actually creates exactly the opposite
scenario that he's warning about he's
like literally dead wrong but this guy
for our technocratic experts is the
expert of the expert of the experts
that's really he's the king maker among
who gets to be these experts who are
going to dictate everything and as i was
saying to tim just a second ago
these guys have quite a track record of
getting some pretty consequential [ __ ]
wrong as we've all seen over the last
couple three years as we say in the
south do you know we read this quote
once and i remember the guy's name but
he said something to the effect of
if these leaders you know these elites
believe that humans are so you know
incapable that they need
special individuals who can lead them
what sets those people apart you know
what i mean like i can't remember what
exactly is something that affects well i
mean the general idea that i mean if you
can't trust people with freedom how can
you trust them with power
if you can't trust uh people to do the
right thing why would that why would
that uh exclude the global elite well
exactly and here's the thing i do
believe that obviously at some point you
need to defer to authority on certain
things but we're not selecting people to
be in positions of authority based on
their moral character at all in fact
we're told we shouldn't even account for
that we should just try to like look at
their policies without questioning what
kind of person they are none of the
people who are in charge of basically
anything consequential have done
anything that i think any of us would
consider really morally impressive
well i mean that's what these guys this
is the same thing that we already have
been circling around a couple of times
as they see themselves as morally
superior to everybody yeah they have so
klaus's vision if we're going to be as
charitable to him as possible is that
the world is entered into a new phase
because of high technology computers ai
um
automation and robots synthetic biology
the capability apparently to unleash
pandemics which he ominously mentions in
kind of weird ways
throughout his books yeah i mean like
lots of these geo-engineering even like
he casually mentions in one of his books
the great narrative the newest one that
maybe will just block out the sun to
stop
for a while to block the stop calling
could a small nuclear war prevent global
warming remember that right 10 years ago
yeah that was ten years ago and um you
know so they just casually flirt with
these he says well because of these
changes that are coming to the world
anyway
because of the rapid changes in
technology et cetera what we need is
people who are really informed about
what these things mean to shepherd us
through so they don't become calamities
like say covet 19 they become something
that we shepherd and use to the benefit
of all and then it's all how do we get
there global cooperation global
governance who's going to be in charge
of it well my ba merry band of experts
you know we have climate experts we have
technology experts we have ai experts we
have all these like like what's it named
uh harare or whatever your evil harare
or we had a world economic forum video a
couple
2019-18 something like this and he's
talking about yeah we're gonna hack
humans like they're a hackable system
we're going to figure out how to hack
humans like we hack computers they're
basically just software but are they
talking about the human mind are they
talking about the human body i think
both and the muscles the neurons and the
muscle and the stomach and we would have
to look up his exact argument it's been
a little bit since i've seen it but the
human mind is actually remarkably easy
to hack in a rudimentary sense the
majority of like hacks when they'll be
like hackers broke into a computer it's
actually human manipulation that's right
that's exactly right which is why for
example why are they making your kids at
school fill out all these damn surveys
all the time like literally survey after
survey what are they doing i didn't hear
about this oh god this is under under
the brand of social and emotional
learning they're constantly trying to
learn more about the children so they
can do the social emotional learning
interventions or whatever it is which
turns out to be maoism by the way but
they're also making them fill out these
surveys and so they're constantly like
how much money do your parents make what
are your views about this how do you
feel about the boobs that you're growing
when you're 12 year old girl that's real
i've seen that it's north carolina
that's real how do you feel about the
changes to your body you're growing
pubic hair how do you feel about that
people look at you and so they're
filling out these things and the goal is
to create
unique profiles for every single
individual in society very much like
what we heard about whether real or not
from cambridge analytica where they were
using personality profiles and then
injecting that into people's social
media to influence their voting habits
influenced voting habits influence
political behavior influence speech
influence thought so that the thought
never enters the mind of the reactionary
you know this influence buying habits i
say that one already um there are a lot
of ties between cambridge and the world
economic forum of course there are and
so this is the idea is that you're
actually going to that's
level one level two is if these fools
get neural implants where we're
literally hooking our brains to the
internet
then you could directly hack you ever
watch stargate sg1 i don't watch
anything you should i should in stargate
sg-1 uh are you familiar with the
concept uh
no so have you seen the movie stargate
okay so military base they played that
thing with the protoss they just oh
starcraft starcraft
they discover a big race and the ring is
you can dial in codes to other stargates
around the the galaxy order yeah
technically it goes beyond the galaxy
and there's other galaxies but uh in one
episode they uh they're exploring so
there's sg one stargate you know okay
they they find a planet that is uh they
open up they open the portal and they
send a robot through
it's like a rover and it's a destroyed
world and so they're like huh this is
weird but then they keep going and all
of a sudden they go through some kind of
like force field and everything's normal
and like nice uh-huh they go inside this
reality
i'm sorry they go inside this the portal
they're wearing special suits they're
walking around this like distressed
planet
like like no no they're in like hazmat
suits oh gotcha because you can't
breathe the air is toxic right but then
they walk through a force field and the
town is normal and they're like there
really does exist a town here with
regular people they begin talking to
people and ask them about their way of
life and they say you know there's just
about a thousand of us who live here our
planet was destroyed and so you know
we've managed to create this force field
which is geothermal powered and it
sustains our life
and uh they're connected to this kind of
uh network that runs and programs
everything for them so they can just
live their lives one day
one of the people they were liaising
with is just gone
and they're like where is so-and-so and
like who and they're like the the woman
that we were talking to negotiating
they're like we don't know you're
talking about and they're like this
little girl your mother and she's like i
don't have a mother and they're like
what and then they uh one day see like
one of the people just walk out into the
dead zone and just like die
as it turns out
the machine could not maintain the force
field and was slowly crunching so what
it did was to maintain order it was
erasing people's memories of their loved
ones to maintain order because the as
this the force field shrank and this is
the the sustainability of the bubble
diminished there were too many people so
they had to keep calling humans and
reducing the number to maintain life in
an orderly fashion
when people plugged themselves into the
machine the machine overwrote their
memories to preserve the system how
malthusian and velda
you see tim
while you were watching star gate i was
studying the blade
that is a mall sword prop for those that
are curious it's like i don't know what
it is
i bought it with my legend of zelda
sword it's junk you are proficient in
the plate are you not
james i mean i can use one it's a moles
you are trained in the martial art you
know in the martial arts
it's well do we want to keep we were
talking about yeah yeah i'm sure if we
want to stand draining marshall because
i don't want to no we should not
brainstorm no we should talk about
things like brain implants and so on
because well why don't we talk about uh
robots yeah well i want to add a point
here because it'll be a good segue to
this yeah because
that's programmable like that's how you
program little simp boys bingo no so
you're we're sort of talking about
neural implants and microchips a person
could potentially put in your brain in
order to hack you i actually think it's
a lot simpler that's much simpler all
you have to know how to do is manipulate
people's emotions with digital boobs
it's incredibly easy to manipulate
people's emotions which is why in the
past
our culture took very seriously the
project of bringing up children who
could make decisions on the basis of
what would be best for themselves and
those around them rather than their raw
emotional reaction to something because
if you can manipulate a person's
emotions but they're a strong and
virtuous person they're going to think
through the way they feel about whatever
situation or idea they've been presented
with
and they're going to react based on
the logical understanding of that
instead of going well i feel like i want
to do this and so i'm going to and i'm
not just talking about emotions like
anger or sorrow i'm talking about things
like lust or even pleasure if you can
get people to
abandon reason whenever it will feel
good to do so they are going to become
unbelievably easy for you to control
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you